[Music]
yeah Janelle Brown's putting her health
first following her split from Cody
we've been separated for several months
what
as the mom explores this new chapter in
her life she's prioritizing her health
sharing this video on Instagram talking
the talk and walking the walk seriously
check out Janelle's form in the gym
[Music]
[Applause]
quote I'm ready for you 2023 this health
Journey I've been on has been incredible
the results weren't overnight and I'm
okay with that it's all about slow and
steady that wins the race 2023 is my
year I'm finding so much value and so
much richness and deepness and it
increases as the years
see for me Janelle's Health kick comes
just days after another big life change
she and Cody split after 29 years of
spiritual marriage Janelle has made it
pretty clear to me that she's
enjoying her life without me
I think if we both really sat down we'd
look at each other and say really so are
you separated yes we are separated it's
easy to start pointing the other ugly
finger to blame
and so no I don't just blame myself
but I do believe that as we go through
struggles there's always plenty of blame
to spread around so with Janelle and
Christine out of the picture what do
Cody's other relationships look like
today well things with Mary continue to
be Rocky but she's still got faith I am
still here because I'm still trying six
years later I'm still here 10 years 15
20 years later I'm still here it's what
I want ironically Mary's trying to
support me and I don't want to be in a
relationship with her anymore and in a
teaser For an upcoming sister wife
special Cody's Legal Wife Robin drops
the bombshell it was Christine who
didn't want Cody with Mary do you think
if Christine didn't object that Mary and
Cody would have gotten back together uh
yeah because when Cody says and thinks
that type of stuff it usually happens
that's a lie that's not me I would never
do that yeah but for Mary it was all a
surprise that Cody even considered
reconciling did you know there was a
moment in the past where he thought
about reconciling
I I don't know what you're talking about
[Music]
it was the
I was no longer angry with her for what
had gone through in my life with her
Mary and I are in an amiable
relationship we've had a real struggle
and this year we have some very
difficult conversations but that
conversation includes
hey
I'm not mad anymore I'm Not Angry
Anymore I'm not hurt anymore so you know
that's real progress
[Music]